well-designed and well executed by
Derrick Henry to Corey Davis on Saturday
that was just a moment where you kind of
accept the fact that the Ravens the best
team in the NFL are going home one of
the very surprising moments from the
divisional round we're going to draft
now Peter King the biggest surprises we
saw in the division around not the
outcomes but specific moments plays
decisions etc be as creative as you care
to be and in lieu of posing the trivia
question
I'm just gonna let you have the purse
first pick because I'm in a good mood
today for a change Mike I'm gonna take
the Bill O'Brien decision to run the
fake field goal fourth and four at your
own twenty one up 17 points midway
through the second quarter
now I thought what has happened has Bill
O'Brien gone and called and hired the
night before the game
John fossil who's gonna go rogue and run
this idiotic play you know with a shirt
tackler Sorenson on the other side on on
that side of the field first of all
great tackle by Sorenson Daniel Sorensen
but second of all you cannot fake a pun
up 17 points deep in your own territory
with four yards to go I just thought it
was one of the most foolish decisions
I've ever seen
Peter I agree with you too and my
immediate reaction was Bill O'Brien has
just told his defense I don't believe in
you I don't think you can hold exactly
I don't trust lead yeah yeah yeah and
and he you know what he was right that's
he was congratulations bill you were
right you shouldn't have trusted your
defense after all but you know what have
that Mike in that way you know what he
did you know what he did he handed the
Chiefs a gimme touchdown okay and so we
can all sit here and say oh my god the
Chiefs seven straight touchdown drives
unbelievable and well I mean twice they
had extremely short fields and that one
because of a bad coaching decision at
least make them go 80 yards yeah it
started with the long kickoff return
from me called Harmon down 24 nothing
continued with the fake punt that failed
and then the following kickoff the ball
squirts out and it's caught in the air
by a Chiefs player and they score a
touchdown not long after that and before
you know it it you know think about what
a blowout that game would have been if
the Texans hadn't racked up 24 out of
the gates 51 to 7 is what the game was
after that it's just amazing to think of
how it turned and how dramatic it was
and how badly the Texans have to feel
but you're right that was a shocker at
the moment because the Texans were in
control and they basically handed it
over to the Chiefs at that point for me
the first one that I'll take and this
one is is is not as obvious as others
would be but it really was a shocker to
watch it play out in real time while we
were there for the Vikings 49ers game
and I want to set this up start of the
second half 49ers up 14 to 10 facing
third and five Jimmy Garoppolo found
Kendrick born for a 20-plus yard gain
great little play born had a significant
impact in the AMA had three catches they
were all very impactful but after that
play after that great throw that great
catch three yards gained after the catch
the 49ers went into run mode
it was 1925 all over again 16 straight
run plays called by Kyle Shanahan after
that successful pass and look along the
way the 49ers put the Vikings away cuz
their defense put the clamps on
Minnesota's offense but to run and and
to be able to run the ball effectively
so you can keep doing it that was the
stunner to me the fact that Kyle
Shanahan kept calling running plays the
fact that they kept gaining yards and
the fact that the Vikings couldn't stop
it for 16 straight plays I can't
remember seeing something like that in a
regular season game much like a pope
must bless a postseason game Peter
[Applause]
that reminded me when I was watching
that happened sort of in real time Mike
I just kept thinking to myself this is
NFC football in 1986 this is the Giants
or Washington or Dallas that more the
Giants in Washington that that just said
listen remember Bill Parcells once told
me that he only had four running plays
and I said you only have four running
plays you know in its in his playbook I
said you only have four running plays
and obviously they did different things
off these running plays but he goes he
goes yeah I'll get more when people can
stop us and people just couldn't stop
him and Kyle Shanahan basically said to
Mike Zimmer hey Mike I'm not gonna I'm
not going to risk stopping the clock
until you stop us once and prevent us
from converting a first down through the
running game yeah and how demoralizing
that has to be for a defense as you feel
your season slipping away and they're in
a damn thing you can do about it all
right round two Peter you're up
all right so Mike the Baltimore Ravens
had the best running game in football in
2019 we all know that they had a
record-setting running game and they had
on their team
a 238 pounding back who averaged 5.3
yards a clip and you're saying jeez I
didn't know Mark Ingram was 238 pounds
he's not Gus Edwards is 238 pounds carry
the ball 133 times in the regular season
he's no neophyte he can play you know
how many rushes he had in a game where
the Ravens were crying out for more of
the power running game three three
rushes in this game it was very clear
entering the game that they had a
wounded bear in Mark Ingram and so
instead of going to the backup who is
clearly good enough to use end to end to
try to pound down the opposition instead
of doing that they basically only gave
the ball to
Gus AdWords in a cameo he had three
rushes and the Ravens I think abandoned
a part of their game that has been there
very good friend all year the power
running game and in that game at home
they seeded the power running game in
this game to the other team to Derek
Henry and I don't think they had to yeah
you know that's a great point Mark
Ingram suffered the calf injury in week
16 didn't play week 17 along with other
key starters it's almost like they
assumed he would be fine and and they
never bothered to revisit during the
game whether he really was fine and
maybe they felt compelled because he was
such a key part of the offense that to
keep going and keep using him even
though he was limited and you got this
other guy who can get it done and at
some point you have to and it all
unfolds so quickly in that 3-hour window
and things are happening and you're
trying to figure out why your defense is
getting gashed and sometimes little
decisions you know you don't have the
ability even an accomplished coach
doesn't have the ability to stop and say
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute we have to take Mark Ingram out
we need to keep using Gus Edwards over
and over and over again if we have any
chance of hanging with this Titans team
so good selection there next one for me
and we had a little hint of it in one of
the TV only segments from earlier in the
hour Jimmy Graham back to the future for
Jimmy Graham what happened to Jimmy
Graham I thought he had retired he
hardly did anything all year long for
the Green Bay Packers the fact that
Aaron Rodgers trusted him in key moments
after he had done nothing for most of
the year and really hasn't done much
during his two years with the team the
27 yard pass over the top the catch by
Jimmy Graham there and then the catch in
the conversion that iced the game Jimmy
Graham a guy that we had given up on
comes back and has a huge game against a
team that I'm you know I think sometimes
the circumstances motivate you and I'd
like to see Jimmy Graham this motivated
every week but I think he was extra
motivated against the Seahawks because
once they traded for him there was all
that talk about how oh he doesn't block
he doesn't do this well he'd never Dean
ever blocked why do you want to take a
square peg and jam it into a round hole
throw the ball to him that's what you're
supposed to do you're not turning him
into a blocking tight end
he's a pass catching
tight end and it never worked in Seattle
and I feel like one of the reasons why
he had that big game is he kind of
wanted to stick it to them a little bit
for never really using him the way that
he's supposed to be used as a pass
catcher Mike a hundred and eighty
degrees different on this did you think
that that ball crossed the line was that
a first down and and whether you say yes
or not here's my question should the NFL
invest time energy and some money with
chip technology putting a chip on each
end of the football so once and for all
and finally we would know whether Jimmy
Graham got it by the yellow line Peter I
will say this and there is a member of
the competition committee who has made
this observation to me many times in the
past the year is 2020 and in football we
still determine whether or not a drive
continues based upon two sticks
connected by ten yards of chain-link
that it does not fly in this day and age
there has to be a better way to use
technology embrace technology whether
it's a chip in the ball whether it's
something else that can create a clear
and unmistakable line to gain that you
know whether you get there you know
whether you don't and the problem here
is because it happened out away from the
hash marks and the lines and the numbers
there was no landmark there was no
objectivity to figuring out where the
ball was in relation to the rest of the
the the field and of course the yellow
line which doesn't show up during the
game itself it's it's it's it's look at
it it's not even where the first down is
anyway so I think that created the
optical illusion for the viewers at home
that Graham didn't get a first down but
the problem is see where he lands if
it's near a hash mark if it's near that
if it's near anything other than green
it's easier to figure out where to put
the ball but that yellow line kind of
screw things up a little bit that yellow
line need to be back some all right
number three for me and I'm kind of what
it would like to go ahead no you go you
go I could go on this all day but you go
all right number three for me
and
the surprise for me came after the
Tennessee Titans game after they beat
the the Baltimore Ravens with that
offense that has been expertly designed
by Arthur Smith the son of FedEx he'll
Fred Smith a couple of Tennessee guys
Fred Smith and Jimmy Haslam I'm
surprised number one Arthur Smith wasn't
a candidate for the Browns job and I'm
surprised after seeing what the Titans
did against the Browns on Saturday night
Jimmy Haslam didn't press pause on
everything and wait for the opportunity
to talk to Arthur Smith before hiring a
head coach because the you know we don't
just pick who the head candy a head
coaching candidates are based on the
regular season at least we shouldn't we
shouldn't look and see what guys do when
the seasons on the line and this goes to
your argument that all of it should be
tabled until after the Super Bowl Peter
if it was all tabled until after the
Super Bowl Arthur Smith would have been
a candidate for multiple jobs he will be
next year but he should be this year but
too late Arthur all jobs are filled the
fact that he didn't emerge as a Browns
candidate in the aftermath that game was
a little bit of a surprise for me
mic you jumped the line you went number
three and you stole my spot in line and
I shall never forgive you for that
how do I say I'm gonna let bygones be
bygones I I was supposed to pick a third
first I'm sorry the rhythm was messed up
because you asked me a question and I
answered and I thought you would made
your pick go ahead I took your spot yeah
my picks are so memorable that you
thought I had made a pick I alright
here's number three here's what
surprised me about Sunday night in the
NFL the warm and fuzzy and sentimental
and nostalgic Aaron Rodgers now don't we
all think that Aaron Rodgers based on
all the things we know about him on and
off the field
mr. private mr. true mr. tough you know
you know basically doing things his own
way everything and Aaron Rodgers after
the game did you see him it was like he
was at a parade down the canyon of heros
you know thanking everybody hey I love
you fans I love you you're wonderful I
love you over here I love you over there
and then afterwards basically spending
about a minute in his press conference
saying you know this was really a great
moment I found myself looking up at all
the waving towels and saying my god this
it's such a it's a treat to play here we
don't have an owner we have a bunch of
people with stock certificates you know
they're my owners and and after
listening to that I said you know Aaron
Rodgers he gets it he's gotten it for a
long time and I'll just tell you a very
quick story last year when I went in to
do the Aaron Rodgers story when Bart
Starr was still alive and he said man
it's a treat I love Bart Starr he's been
meant everything to me at one point we
were out there with the NBC crew looking
up and I said man there's Nitschke
there's Starr there's Lombardi they're
all up there I said you're gonna be up
there one day he goes maybe and you
could tell by his wide grin that that's
going to be one of the great days in his
lot
and I just thought it was very cool and
a little unexpected that Aaron Rodgers
would soak it in right in the middle of
the playoffs I loved it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports